jean françois lisée merci nous accorder
un peu de temps cette fin de campagne
céline galipeau toujours un plaisir de
venir répondre à vos questions vous
savez beaucoup d'analystes qui disait
que vous faisiez un parcours sans faute
une très bonne campagne et puis là
depuis le débat de jeudi dernier vous
vous acharnez sur québec solidaire mais
bien des gens se demandent pourquoi
qu'est ce que vous essayez de faire
c'est à dire que ce qui est particulier
c'est que la pire question que j'ai
posée juste dit dernier elle était
adressée à philippe couillard j'ai dit
comment ça se fait il y avait 2
milliards de surplus pivot compression
forcé une dame à dormir sur sa chaise
roulante c'était la pire question la
deuxième pire c'était à françois legault
quand j'ai dit vous ne savez pas là mais
vous dites que la diplomation vaut mieux
en ontario à cause des maternelles
catraio pas un seul enfant des matériels
quatre ans qui a été diplômé et la
troisième moins pire des trois a été la
question posée à man o man c'est
pourquoi est-ce que ça étonné c'est
parce que jusque-là personne posait de
questions à manon massé elle avait une
partie gratuite et moi vers la fin la
capelle guibert
c'est quand même pas normal qu'on soit
pas équitable les on a vers les autres
et donc j'ai voulu rétablir l'équité en
cette fin de campagne
alors que l'intérêt pour le pour québec
solidaire est en croissance on le voit
tous je dis bien ce serait normal que on
traite avec équité tous les partis mais
est-ce que vous allez pas faire un pacte
avec ce parti losc ne connaissez pas la
structure et le programme de ce parti là
je connais déjà
on l'a découvert il ya deux ans
lorsqu'on a offert fait cette tentative
de mettre le bien commun au delà de nos
intérêts partisans
on a négocié avec quelqu'un qui était co
porte parole dont on pensait qu'ils
avaient le pouvoir et on s'est rendu
compte que cette personne là étaient
traités comme quantité négligeable pas
ceux qui ont le vrai pouvoir accusations
mais quelque chose de laid chose de
mystérieux dans la façon dont tu es
fonctionne il y avait des gens qui dans
q s était d'accord avec nous et vous
allez voir nous on va voir on va
renverser
on veut gagner la majorité face à ceux
qui sont dogmatiques qui veulent pas
d'alliance
ils ont été battus il est optimiste
parce qu'il ya 87 % des électeurs de qu
est ce qui vous laisse pas tu mets donc
on a appris à ce moment là que les co
porte parole
sont bien gentils mais c'est pas eux qui
ont le pouvoir et donc je pense que ça
fait partie de notre devoir de
transparence de dire aux gens il ya
quelque chose que vous savez pas est ce
que vous vous trompez pas de cible
cependant il ya sept jours de campagne
est ce que vraiment vous attaquez à
qu'un parti progressiste souverainiste
peut-être plus proche du vôtre que la
caq élus libéraux est ce que c'est pas
se tromper de cible
notre adversaire c'est les libéraux
c'est ce gouvernement qui sent les gens
parlent tous les jours mais je remarque
que vos collègues comme ces nouveaux
comptes traite équitablement québec
solidaire sont intéressés par cet
élément de nouveauté chez comment ça
fonctionne mais nous ne voulons pas que
les libéraux continuent à gouverner
il ya soixante dix pour cent des
québécois qui sont d'accord avec çà et
là on arrive en rangs dispersés
le parti qui peut regrouper rassembler
des gens qui sont pour l'entreprise
privée l'entrepreneuriat les régions le
nationalisme économique et des gens qui
sont progresser s'ils veulent qu'ils
rencontrèrent un une action très forte
sur l'environnement c'est au parti
québécois qui peuvent se rassembler
c'est pas à la caq né à québec solidaire
qui sont sur les flancs de ce
rassemblement nous on a des gens dans
notre grande coalition on a réussi à
faire une synthèse de ça et surtout le
test de la crédibilité contrairement à
la caq nous nous avons passé le test de
crédibilité mais en vous en prenant
justement à québec solidaire et vous
insistez quand même pour le faire il ya
les journalistes mais vous le faites
aussi est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en
train de plomber votre campagne est ce
que on se demande si c'est pas un peu
désespérée que vous avez peur de vous
quoi de vous faire doubler par québec
solidaire même à montréal dans votre
circonscription
je suis très confortable d'un
heureusement au lion aux yeux un vrai
sondage qui montrait que j'étais dix
points en avance tout le reste ce sont
des extrapolations de trucs nationaux
qui valent ce qu'ils valent
non moi je pense que dans les derniers
jours la campagne
les québécois doivent avoir la vérité
sur chacun des partis qui se présentent
et effectivement la résultante de ma
questions factuelles de judy c'est que
jamais auparavant
n'at-on autant scruter le programme de
québec solidaire et il serait très
dommage parce que on se divise que les
libéraux réussisse à se faufiler avec
avec les conséquences de cette question
le fond vous aviez
raison de poser des questions soient
québec solidaire mais sur la forme en
prendre comme ça de façon si frontale
avec attaqué de façon si frontale manon
ma 6t pensez vraiment que c'était une
bonne idée
adam galipeau je vais répondre à toutes
les questions que vous posez mais je
remarque qu'elles sont toutes sur québec
solidaire depuis le début de cette
entrevue
moi j'ai des choses à dire sur la santé
sur l'éducation sur l'a4 soit pq sur
l'indépendance sur l'environnement est
ce que le problème plus fondamental
c'est pas que le parti québécois a du
mal incarné le changement surtout auprès
des jeunes
ce qui fait justement montée québec
solidaire ce que c'est pas ça le
problème plus fondamental
ce dont je suis extrêmement fier depuis
que je suis chef du parti québécois
c'est non seulement de constater que
plus de jeunes qui sont membres du parti
québécois que dans tous les autres
partis et même plus de membres jeunes du
pq que la totalité des membres de
certains partis de deux autres partis
que le nombre de jeunes qui ont pris des
positions de pouvoir au sein du pq sous
ma direction a augmenté considérablement
la moyenne d'âge du conseil exécutif
national est de 35 ans et c'est moi qui
la tire vers le haut notre présidente
est la plus jeune de l'histoire
le nombre de candidats ex et y que nous
avons lancé prédominant mais alors
comment vous expliquez que votre parti
stagne dans les sondages quand même qu
est-ce qui passe comment ça se fait que
le message semble pas passer cette
élection est tellement volatile le
nombre de gens qui changent d'avis le
nombre de gens qui disent le deuxième
choix que nous avons c'est le pq c'est
massif à la cac et accusent leur
deuxième choix cpq le nombre de gens qui
se décide dans les derniers 24 heures
est en augmentation alors de dire qui va
gagner
lundi prochain à partir de ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui je vous le conseille pas
nous notre grand défi depuis le
printemps
c'était d'être entendus et cette
campagne si ce qui fait qu'on a augmenté
ce qui fait qu'on est entendu ce qui
fait qu'on dit qu'on a une bonne
campagne ce qui fait que mon imagination
personnel par exemple dans le public
augmente considérablement c'est qu'enfin
c'est pas que notre message était est
différent c'est qu'on a plus de
capacités d'être entendu de dire qui on
est ce qu'on veut faire
quel est notre attitude on a on est
sérieux on fait des blagues on est bon
enfant mais on est sérieux on est de
notre temps on défend par exemple
liberté d'expression dans les affaires
cela avec kanata janeiro ont été les
plus présents pour la liberté
d'expression
on est d'un autre temps on est vraiment
le parti du 21e siècle et qui regarde
vers l'avant il reste sept jours de
campagne enfin une semaine qu'est ce que
ça va être la question de l'eau d'hélium
pour vous la crédibilité je pense que
d'abord le changement c'est acquis ok la
majorité veulent du changement ça c'est
fait qui peut porter le changement et
qui peut rassembler pour empêcher les
libéraux de gagner parce qu'on va
revenir à cette question là à la fin
c'est un vent de fraîcheur qu'on amène
et on pense que les gens ont dit ok à la
fin la puis même si je veux pas
l'indépendance
le pq s'est engagé à ce qu'il ait pas de
référendum dans le premier mandat
on voit c'est le bon choix mais je pense
qu'il va s'imposer par la dernière
semaine donc à qui vous allez parler
surtout dans cette dernière semaine à
qui vous parlez moment on parle à tous
les québécois qui ont soif de changement
puis qui veulent pas se faire avoir
puis on dit écoutez là quatre couleurs
vous avez vu la cie un peu se faire
avoir
ils ont un cadre financier et ont pas
trouvé un seul économiste indépendant
pour dire que ça balançait à leurs
affaires puis nous on pense que vous
allez vous faire avoir il va avoir des
compressions parce qu'il ya 3 milliards
qui sont de la magie à québec solidaire
il ya des choses qui vous disent pas et
plus vous en apprenez plus vous rendez
compte que c'est pas vraiment crédible
leur affaire mais nous on a été
transparent depuis le début on vous dit
qui on est ce qu on fait comment on le
fait il n'y a pas de cachettes et on a
passé les tests de crédibilité
environnementale économique on a des
économistes qui ont dit vous êtes les
plus économes vous êtes les plus les
plus conservateurs en ce sens qu'on veut
jamais se trouver dans une situation où
on va faire comme philippe couillard
peut dire à une personne handicapée
regarde je te coupe d'autonomes d'heures
de soins à domicile parce que c'est ça
prend déficit zéro alors je pense que je
vais aller répéter se divisent nous nous
sommes le changement crédible dont vous
avez besoin vous souhaite une bonne fin
de campagne jean françois lisée
merci céline galipeau